I've been researching chlorine dioxide, which used to be called MMS,
miracle, literal solution or something like that. I purchased some pre-made solution.
Do you think there is any reason not to consume this throughout the day with the protocol
and currently on? I've been back to daily and fed me four days, three days off.
So, you know, just having this question on our, if I posted this video, just to say those words,
chlorine dioxide, and we posted this to YouTube, YouTube would ban us. That's how we got
some of these strikes on YouTube is somebody asked a question about chlorine dioxide. So,
we'll make sure we don't post this video to YouTube. It's just so sad. I mean, they say that
they're not, you know, doing this anymore. They're still doing it just as much. It's just ridiculous.
Okay, so what is chlorine dioxide? Chloride dioxide is a chlorine solution. So it's not chlorine that
you would buy in the store, but it's similar. It's just one molecule away, one atom away from it being
chlorine. So, it is still a caustic substance, and that's how it can work. It is a oxidative substance.
Now, if you read my article, Heartic state oxidative stress to kill cancer in the blog,
you'll see that there's, that different nutrients are oxidative at different doses. So,
high dose vitamin C is oxidative. Low dose vitamin C is an antioxidant.
High dose vitamin E is oxidative. Low dose vitamin E is antioxidant, same thing with melatonin,
same thing with selenium, same thing with multiple other supplements. Plus a lot of other supplements
that are cancer-killing supplements that have been, you know, having cancer, quote, cancer-killing
properties over the years, like, like, vitamin B17 and, you know, high dose different herbs,
like the hoxy type herbs and seaccharbs. They work because they're oxidative. Now, chloride
dioxide is an oxidative substance, too. So, would it be good for cancer? Yes, in a sense, yes, in a
high dose, it would be good for cancer. The only negative of that is that, whereas high dose
aren't emisited, or high dose vitamin C, or high dose B17 will kill cancer cells, but it tends
to spare healthy cells. So, high dose selenium, it's never going to hurt anybody. It's not going to
cause cancer because it's oxidative. It's not going to cause cancer to healthy cells, whereas
chemotherapy is oxidative. And it will kill cancer cells, but it can actually cause cancer to
healthy cells, and it can kill healthy cells because it doesn't spare healthy cells. While chloride dioxide
doesn't spare healthy cells, either. Hypervectin and bedbenazole work on a different pathway. They
don't work to kill cancer because they're oxidative. They work to kill cancer for different pathways
the main pathway, I believe, is that it up regulates the P53 tumor suppressor gene pathway.
Chlorid dioxide can be beneficial for cancer patients because it's oxidative, but it doesn't
spare healthy cells. So, it can damage healthy cells. That is typically why we don't typically
recommend it for cancer patients. Now, back in the day, we used to see a lot of line patients. We
had a lot of people on chloride dioxide because it can be really beneficial to kill
pathogens. It can kill lime and its co-infections, so it can be beneficial that way.
So, if I all mean you can take it if you want to, and the question really is, is it going to
negatively affect your current protocol? I would say no, it's not going to negatively affect
your current protocol. It's working a completely different pathway than hypervectin and bedbenazole,
and it's working on a different pathway than any or other stuff that's your own cell.